um if we could please play plaintiff's
exhibit 397 which is already in evidence
i wish i hadn't bought into any of your
lives your [ __ ] your sober
presence your
goodness your sweetness all the lies i
wish i hadn't bought into the months of
you being you i wish i bought promises i
wish i thought i could have kids with
you you're [ __ ] yourself i wish i
hadn't bought into any of the lives you
sold talk about fake billing goods come
on go be a real married man and go deal
with your weight that a man does go run
to the next house
every man does
go
run away i know what's happening
ridiculous crime it's hard panic
hard it's hard screwing everybody up
[Laughter]
you're right you got it figured
hey
at least i didn't do like
a tv show where i was hurtful
in my 20s god that would be like
embarrassing
if only i was with someone in their 50s
that could point that out to me imagine
mine you're right when you play a
non-sexualized object okay
wow
you're right you got you gotta all
figured out
i don't even know what movies are done
you haven't even taken the introduction
if only i could be like
you reckon you trying to like you're
jokes you are
blind you're a joke
you're a joke
yeah i'm the joke in the industry amber
i'm the joke i'm the joker
i can't really hear you i'm sorry the
ring runs of all my [ __ ] playing too
loud let me hear you i'm gonna just go
and
peddle my way back sorry
i was expressing frustration
about
his criticism of my career and how many
problems that cost within the dynamic of
our relationship yes so you call them a
sellout and a joke i call them horrible
ugly things as you can hear
sell out we spoke to each other in a
really horrible way
pretty sure we just heard you speak to
him in a really horrible way you called
him a sellout i just missed her um you
called him a sellout right misheard i
called him a lot of ugly and a joke i
called him a lot of ugly things you
called him a joke on that recording you
called him a washed up piece of
i think we both called each other that
on that uh occasion yes mr depp mentions
aquaman doesn't he yes he does said i
got you that role in aquaman didn't he
excuse me mr depp
got you that role in aquaman didn't he
no miss vasquez i got myself that role
by auditioning
that's why that says quote your jealousy
is so tragic
i heard him say that yes
you were the jealous one in this
relationship weren't you misheard i
think he was indicating i was jealous of
his career
but now you've twisted it to say it was
mr depp that's the jealous one
johnny's always been very jealous when i
worked when i did anything friends yes
he's always been very jealous
he changed the locks to the penthouses
on may 22nd 2016. i attempted to
that's why you felt comfortable having
james franco over the evening of may
22nd 2016 miss herd
i do not know when
i do not know when james came over okay
let's remind you can we please pull up
planters exhibit 304 which is already in
evidence
that's you and mr franco on may 22nd
2016 right ms hurd that's correct and
you're taking him up to the penthouses
aren't you that's where i lived yes and
it's past 11 p.m at night isn't that
right i'm not quite sure the time it
looked it looked like that why don't we
pull that video back up
2251.
almost midnight right that's excuse me
almost 11 o'clock at night exactly
okay
knew mr depp was out of town the week of
may 21 2016 didn't you
i don't know what i knew of his schedule
at the time
knew mr depp was out of town on may 27th
when you went to get the domestic
violence restraining order isn't that
right i don't know if i knew that at the
time
you knew you knew mr depp was heading
out on a european tour that week isn't
that right i'm not quite sure what i
understood of his schedule at that time
you knew he wouldn't be back for weeks
right no that's incorrect you wrote this
op-ed right miss heard
with the help of the aclu yes
that's what you testified to in this
courtroom right that is correct
and this was published on december 18
2018 correct
that is correct
aquaman was released on december 21st
2018 right that is yes that sounds
correct that was your first
big
blockbuster big budget role right
i i disagree but it was the first time i
had like a
a leading role in a movie of that size
yes
well second time yes
what was your first time the first one
was the film i talked about before i
mean yesterday um justice league it
introduced the character so
you know technically it was the second
one but you were the love interest in
aquaman correct that is correct
now at least parts of this op-ed are
about mr depp isn't that right
it's about what happened to me after
you sat here during opening statements
when your attorney argued that the
context of your statements in this op-ed
matter correct
that's correct so let's go through some
of that context
he wrote here quote
friends and advisors told me i would
never work again as an actress that i
would be blacklisted
referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp in the
statement aren't you
can you repeat the question i'm sorry
you're referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp
in the statement aren't you um in
general i'm referring to being
associated with domestic violence
and you're referring to what you claim
happened after you got an ex-party
domestic violence restraining order
against mr depp in may of 2016. right
are you asking me if that's what i was
writing about
that's what you're referring to correct
can you just give me the question again
i'm sorry you're referring to what you
claim happened after you got an ex-party
restraining order against mr depp in may
of 2016. that's correct
you also wrote
questions arose as to whether i would be
able to keep my role of mira in the
film's justice league and aquaman
this is also
referring to your accusations of
domestic violence against mr depp right
this is referring to what happened to me
after i got my tro my restraining order
against mr depp right that is correct
these questions arose only after you
accused mr depp of domestic violence in
may of 2016 allegedly right
yeah from the time i got the tro being
associated with domestic violence that's
what it's a reference to yes
let's pull up please plaintiff's exhibit
3 which is already in evidence
this is a tweet from your twitter
account on december 19 2018 correct that
is correct
you're on our i'm
oh it's already in evidence it is
inevitable
thank you so on december 19th 2018 you
tweeted quote today i published this
op-ed in the washington post did i read
that right that is correct and the tweet
includes a link to the op-ed we were
just looking at correct that's correct
and you can see that the title of the
op-ed in your tweet is quote opinion
amber heard i spoke up against sexual
violence
right
yes you don't get to change the title of
an article you're retweeting
and that's the title that you put on
your twitter correct i did not put it on
my twitter no you linked it to your
tweet i retweeted the article
you published it
i retweeted a link to an article that
i wrote and you publish it on your
twitter account all right i retweeted it
you testified yesterday that you didn't
have any control over the title and just
now
of the op-ed when you retweeted it is
that correct that is correct
this wasn't a retweet though right
tweet
perhaps not retweet i don't i'm not
quite sure it was a tweet tweet
i misspoke excuse me tweet not retweet
you included a link to the electronic
copy of the op-ed in your tweet right
that's what i was trying to say earlier
um and i might have missed it's like i'm
trying to attach it right
so you can cr included a link right yes
that's correct okay that's correct
so you must have seen the title of the
electronic version of the op-ed before
you tweeted it right i may have i just
didn't notice it
not very careful about what you
published are you misheard
i just didn't notice the title
you didn't need to include the link to
the electronic version the op-ed in your
tweet did you
how else would i have
linked it
well you didn't need to include the link
to tell the world that today you had
published this op-ed in the washington
post about women who are challenging
their rage and about violence and
equality into political strength despite
the price of coming forward
right i couldn't attach it with a paper
clip no but you didn't need to attach it
at all to tell the world that you had
published an op-ed no the goal was to to
tweet about it and to provide a link so
that people could read it the op-ed is
in your name right that's correct
so if you had noticed the title of the
electronic version of the op-ed before
you included it in your tweet you could
have asked the washington post to change
it isn't that right
uh no that's not okay but you didn't do
that right you never asked the
washington post to change the title i
didn't notice it and i didn't ask them
nor do i think i needed to
at the bottom do you see that there's
another tweet from december 19 2018
yes i do
and in this one
it reads i am honored to announce my
role as an aclu ambassador on women's
rights did i read that right that's
correct so you announced your aclu
ambassadorship the same day you posted
the op-ed on your twitter i think that
was always the plan is to attach the
article with the
the announcement that i was an
ambassador
you